afternoon everybody this is Peter Cooper
from the NCBI today we're going to have
a webinar that's going to show you some
teaching examples that use our blasts
service this is another this is a second
in the series of these teaching example
handouts that we make that we
distributed at conferences and off of
our FTP site and this this was presented
in part at a cell biology conference a
few years ago by the way my name is
Peter Cooper as I said if you need to
get in touch with me that's my email
address peter cooper at nih gov so as i
mentioned we had these case study
teaching examples there are three of
them on the ftp site we talked about the
one using entree direct last time that i
gave a webinar this one's going to be
about using blast and the idea behind
these is you can use them if you teach
undergraduate courses that involve
bioinformatics we're using blast you can
use these as sort of starting points for
making your own examples so here's what
we're gonna do today we're gonna talk a
little bit about blast just to make a
few tips about blast and I think
everybody should know to do a little
evangelism about some things that we had
the helpdesk would like people to know
talk about some related alignment
services and then we'll go through the
examples we're going to use five
different ones one of them has to sort
of two parts one of them's going to be
identifying bacteria using 16s ribosomal
RNA sequences we're gonna design primers
for a gene product and a gene we're
gonna make some trees using some of the
add-ons to blast we're gonna do one that
shows the phylogeny of the Apes using
mitochondrial genomes one that shows the
evolution protein evolution where there
are a number of paralogs off creating
kinases and we can make a protein tree
we're going to annotate an unintended
bacterial contig and then we're gonna
map a protein in fact the same one that
we got from that bacterial contact onto
a conserved domain and a 3d structure
for that protein so a couple of things
what's blast anyway this is probably the
most widely used sequence similarity
search tool in the world it finds
high-scoring local alignments between
two sequences it includes a model of
score distributions for Rand
local alignments which means that it can
provide statistical significance for
alignments and the main statistic there
is you expect value which is the number
of hits the same or better score that
you would expect by chance in practice
that doesn't actually come up that much
in people's everyday searches we'll talk
about why that is in a moment just to
remind you what blast tells you about it
tells you about these non chance
similarities between biological
sequences if they're not due to chance
then they're due to something else
these high-scoring similarities homology
is a classic thing that blast is about
these things are related because they're
evolved from this common ancestor but in
practice these days a lot of times blast
is use simply to identify something I'll
talk more about that in a moment in
order to use blast of course you have to
have a nucleotide or protein sequence so
these are sort of the three related
things that blast does it can answer the
following kinds of questions
what's my sequence related to and what
does it do this is about homology or the
presence of conserved domains is it
already in the database that's
identification so you're gonna find them
matching sequence or as we'll see today
you could find the organism that that
sequence probably belonged to methyl
last thing is about sort of assembly or
annotation issues where is it located
how is it organized what kinds of things
are on my sequence here's a to the
evangelism part that I wanted to mention
and this has to do with the size of the
blast databases and some rules that you
should think about the blast databases
are quite large
many of the default ones in particular
are enormous and in general the bigger
the search space the longer the search
takes and I will add the more likely it
is to fail which happens a bit and the
expect value for a particular hit
increases linearly with the size of the
database now that's kind of a cryptic
statement so you take it apart and think
about what it means what it means is
this you are much more likely to be able
to get and interpret your results if you
search the smallest database that is
likely to contain this target of
interest and that's one of the things I
want points I want to make today
most searches are against the default
databases consider searching other
databases we're gonna look at some of
those today refseq protein the model
organisms database 16s ribosomal RNA
database and always I can't think of an
example where you wouldn't want to do
this use an organism or an entree query
to limit the size of the database
further and you can adjust the expect
value cutoff to limit to only
significant matches we'll see some
examples of that today just a couple
more words about the program's the
nucleotide search programs by default we
use a thing called mega blast that
discontiguous megablast there will be
times when you may need to make the
search more sensitive in fact I'll use
contiguous mega blast to make a search
for sensitive today so you can change
the particular nucleotide search program
for protein searches you can do a
straight blast P which is protein
against protein you can also translate
and we're going to do a blast X search
today to look at an unattainable eat I'd
sequence we're also going to run a
conserved main search which tells us
about functional elements or you know
similar kinds of structures and things
like that and this has a greater
look-back time and it tells you more
about the structure function of the
protein than an ordinary placer does
that runs every time you run a blast
search also going to use some other
alignment services today these are not
blast they're related things primer
blast which will help you design primers
that are specific and no one amplify
other things in database mole blast is
just kind of a demonstration program but
it will use it with with our 16s it's a
good thing for clustering these things
and finding out what the sources are and
cobalt which is our protein multiple
alignment tool okay how do you get the
blast the blast homepage has access to
all the different programs and in fact
any of the main programs you can change
what kind of search you're doing right
on the page the other tools that we're
going to that are listed at the bottom
here the ones we're going to use today
our mole blast
primer blast and we're going to use a
multiple alignment search so here are
the things we're going to do identify
uncultured bacterial 16s sequences
design primers sample
by the coding region of a gene human
myeloperoxidase the transcript and if we
and I'll show you at least starts you
want to getting exon ten we're gonna
make phylogenetic trees based on eight
mitochondrial genome sequences and in
I'm using a panda broad sense here that
it includes human and also tetrapod
vertebrates cretan kinase genes
tetrapods are creatures with four legs
like us although we call it two of them
arms then we're gonna take Cody regions
on a prokaryotic genomic sequence from
meta-genome we're going to find
conserved domains in that particular
uncharacterized bird so what I'll do for
each search is I'll just set it up and
we'll go ahead and show you what happens
when we do it so we're gonna the first
one is going to be identifying these
twenty uncultured bacterial 16s
sequences that are in the database they
don't tell you much about them just that
they're ribosomal RNAs so we can use 16s
rRNA type strains database which is on
the blast page get a distance tree of
results me know if you like those things
and we can look at ball blast to do this
so let's set that one up I'm going to go
to the website and what I've got up here
is just a little cheat sheet for me
because and this is one of the documents
that's in there so we can use these
twenty uncultured bacterial sequences
that are listed here and I made myself a
little link that basically just is a URL
to retrieve these and there they are and
so you know you don't actually need to
visit the blast homepage to run blast
from the nucleotide pages you can simply
click this run blast link here my twenty
are in there and then this is where
we're going to do some things to help us
we're going to change the database so
the sequences that I'm talking about are
in the default database but there's a
lot of other stuff in there so the one
we want is a 16s ribosomal RNA sequence
database that contains type strain
sequences that ncbi has curated and
identify now not everything is in there
but a lot of things are in there so we
can set that up and run the search and
to save time
I'm not going to spend our time running
searches I've actually got the our IDs
available so we can just retrieve them
and these should last for several months
there is also a link that will help you
set it if you want to just set up the
page the way I have it set up you can
just use this compressed URL link here
and that will set it up but what I'm
going to do is go ahead and retrieve the
results so we can take a look at them so
this is we did 20 sequences and we have
20 different results pages here if we
wanted to get them all on one page we
could do that by downloading them and so
we can see if we managed to identify
them what we can do to do that you can
scroll through these you can see that
you have the coverage of 99 percent over
a lot of these where you have a type
strain named here Shigella dysentery and
so we can be fairly confident that this
is probably a good species or genus
level identification of this sequence
you can just sort of run through them
one at a time if you want to to see that
most of these have been at least
identified fairly closely for any one of
these we could take a look at a distance
for you the results here don't go ahead
and do for this one we'll come back to
this in a little bit and you can see
where it fits in here you can expand
this to see what organisms are in there
we can zoom and to find that query
sequence that we want to and so it's
these clusters right there with Shigella
so we can pretty be pretty confident
that that's probably a CBL sequence a
lot of these will cluster together as
Cherie she and Shigella actually belong
really to the same genus as an extension
of this we can use mole-blast to look at
this a little bit to show you a way of
clustering all these things together and
I'll just show you that quickly won't go
back over here to my whole blast is of
course linked to the last home page but
I can simply grab the URL here to go
there directly I think I need to mole
blast CGI on there but there it is on
the bottom of the page here and I can
take those sequences there we had a
moment ago and put them all in there
you know
my database here - the one that I talked
about before the 16s ribosomal RNA
sequences and I can just run that this
has this does a blast search but it also
does a full multiple sequence alignment
on these sequences and then it will give
me a tree that clusters and what's good
about this is a clusters them not only
with the 16s sequences but also with
each other and so I selected several
that are probably from the same species
and so we'll see that result show up
here when we do that so while that's
cooking I'm just gonna go back to my
slides and we'll come back to that
result in just a moment so the next
thing I wanted to show you is how to use
fire blast and we're going to design
primers for a Mylo peroxidase we're
going to do a couple of interesting
things you're going to use the features
table to get a sub-region
and we'll design primers we can check
those primers and we're going to use
some of the special databases that are
refseq databases on the primer blast
page to make our results more specific
so let's let mole-blast continue to run
go back over here and we'll start on
this particular one so what I want to do
is to retrieve the sequence that we're
going to work with which is a mile of
peroxidase sequence
so this is a human messenger RNA and
what we might want to do is amplify a
particular portion of this from some
kind of a cDNA experiment some kind of a
library and so I noticed that I can go
down here to the feature table and I can
select this CBS the coding region that's
going to be from a start codon to the
stop codon of the sequence if I click on
that it gives me it's it highlights it
for me there's the ATG start right there
I can display this it doesn't matter
what format I'm just going to pick fast
a and so then what I can do is go over
here and pick primers and that's going
to basically just give me this sequence
as a template and primer-blast
how to use primer blast what I have to
do is I can there's all kinds of
settings that have to do with the
primers specificity and things like that
and I'll go ahead and leave those alone
the main thing primer-blast does it's a
blast is it checks your primers at the
end to see if they're going to amplify
additional things in the database and so
you have to set a database down here and
this is the organism limit which will
use more in a few minutes that that's
the tax ID for human it's exactly the
same as doing this so we could run that
if we want and primer-blast takes a
moment to run so I'll go ahead and cut
to the chase and show you my results
that are over here one of the things
that I did have to do that I didn't
point out and is point it out to you in
the instructions this the size of this
amplified sequence here is fairly large
it's over 2,400 bases long and that's a
bit large for PCR people usually want
shorter ones than that but you can do it
so I had to adjust that parameter on
primer-blast order to get this result so
then I have a set of primers here there
are 10 primer pairs by default they also
be equally good and they would amplify
this entire coding region here which is
actually highlighted for you up here and
this viewer of the messenger RNA
sequence
so we're back to looking at mole-blast
this just shows you that we have the
results are finished here I just wanted
to point out to you that we can see
those now go ahead expand this one of
the things about the tree viewer is if
you have a big screen it works a little
bit better than it does on a little
screen like a laptop just where I am
right now
but you can see our bacterial clones and
how they cluster within the different
groups of bacteria here and make luster
with each other so these are probably
from very closely related organisms and
this is probably not one of the ones
that does it we probably don't have this
particular organism perhaps represented
in our database it depends these ones
that have sort of longer branch things
here okay that's an aside let's go back
to what we were doing before which is
working on primer-blast now I'm going to
go ahead and close them all blast here
now one of the things that we might want
to do is to see if our primers that we
just designed would amplify these
particular sequences from other
organisms so I can basically take these
primers and put them back into viral
essences using primer blast in a
different way I'll go ahead and just
show you that set up so I'm going to
take the two primers that we just
designed there we go so I put the two
primers that we just designed in here
and what I've done is I've changed the
the organism restriction here so that
we're now looking at primates and we
could see if we could amplify the this
particular transcript from other primate
transcriptomes that we have in the
database and that result is over here
that result is over here and this is so
here's the one of the gibbons we
definitely would amplify that here's the
human one we already know about that
there is a gorilla chimpanzee bonobo one
of the orangutangs
I'm not sure what Seba says I think it's
an old word monkey you know world monkey
and or monkey here and so on and so
forth now you can see that some of these
have mismatches and if you adjust your
strategy properly you might not amplify
them but for the higher primates you've
only got like one mismatch so the
chances are they would probably work
okay and so you can do exactly the same
thing and I won't go through this one
but I'll set it up for you you could
start on the refseqgene record for this
and you could easily get exon ten from
the featured table and go ahead and
analyze that to find primers that would
amplify that so let's do at least one of
the phylogenetic trees and I think the
ape mitochondrial genome is a good one
to do what we're going to do here is
we're going to restrict a particular
database refseq genomic which contains
all of our genomic reference sequences
we're going to limit it to great apes or
to ieaves in general and and we're going
to use an organism and an entree filter
to limit that database just the
sequences of interest and we can again
manipulate the tree viewer display to
get a particular kind of tree out of
this so let's go to the website again so
what I want to do is to get a particular
sequence as a query and what I've done
is I've chosen what a lot of taxonomy or
a phylogeny type people call an
out-group sequence this is from a
primate that's more distantly related to
the Apes like humans and things like
that this is a ring-tailed lemur it's a
lot of people are familiar with to set
this up I would simply choose run blast
here change my database to refseq
genomic enter my organism name here
which is hominoid iya which is a super
family that contains a grade it decays
humans and the other apes and I'm also
going to put an entre query limit in
here that would limit to the
mitochondrial sequences because
sometimes there are mitochondrial
sequences within the nuclear genome and
this is the mitochondrial genome of the
Lemur up here I can also to make it a
little more sensitive I'll pick one of
the more sensitive algorithms here
discontiguous megablast you can also
adjust algorithm parameters down here
such as the e-value so I want to make it
so that things are fairly stringent so I
could put one in here like one you know
minus 64 that means it really would be
no chance then these are random
alignments these are going to be things
that are distinctly significant I'm
gonna go ahead and recruit that result
for you so now I have it's to several
other great apes here you might
recognize the names of these are going
to be chimpanzees bonobos gorillas Simon
is one of them and the Gibbons and I can
use the distance tree of results to get
the tree this is an interesting display
here but a little bit more useful is to
do something like change the way this is
laid out and let's make it a circular
tree
so here are the humans and notice that
there are extinct humans people call
this as a tribe homey nee hoor homonyms
the closest related relatives to us are
the chimpanzee and the bonobo which are
over here and here are the other great
apes in the same family we are the
family hominid II is here these are the
Gibbons in the sime Aang over here and
then here is our out group which is a
lemur mitochondrial genome and I'll
leave you with this one is it's sort of
an example that you can run yourself
this is the homology search using
creatine kinase ins it's the same
principle as the one we just did except
this time we're going to be making a
protein tree and because there are
numerous paralogs in here you're going
to have multiple homologues in the same
species which we call para logs the
extension of this is that you can run
cobalt directly from the blast results
to generate your phylogenetic tree but
it's pretty much exactly the same
procedure and you can use the links that
are in the handout to get there if you
want to let's skip ahead and we'll go
ahead and do this one and then we'll
probably need to wrap this up this is
identifying a coding region on a genomic
sequence and we're going to use a
particular sequence from a marine
meta-genome that's uh Nana Tate 'add
when I search against a small database
called a landmark database that will
give us some particularly good matches
from organisms where we know something
about them and it contains sort of all
groups of organisms archaea bacteria
plants animals and so we can do that to
get a particular set of results so let's
go here to the website so we're going to
do is start with a particular conduct
from this you carry out just this
prokaryotic marine meta-genome and so
this has no annotation associated with
it we can run blast with it and what
we're going to do is change this up a
little bit we're going to go to a
translating blast search this is blast X
and so we're going to use the bacteria
and archaea and we're going
use landmark while organisms we can
either leave it like this with archaea
and bacteria as a potential because I
know this is a prokaryotic or I can do
the whole thing and leave it wide open
and I think the one that I showed you
was doing leaving the whole thing wide
open I did change a couple of parameters
here the e-value threshold is set to a
more significant value one times 10 to
the minus 6 which is something I suggest
you always do and I set the word size
from the default of 6 to 3 to make this
a more sensitive search that's great to
see a quick look at those results and so
here's our query sequence each one of
these matches is through a protein from
one of the organisms proteomes that's in
the database so for example here's a
half nuclease another helicase these are
all related proteins there's a DNA
topoisomerase one and the other titles
are all that DNA till probably summaries
one here is a tRNA like aids for alanine
it's all annotated that way
it's from various organisms and they all
mala G extends across into the plants
there so you can see evidence for 1 2 3
4 5 maybe 6 protein coding genes the
best hit is to one of this one of this
our keel sequence it's in the database
the fan or thermo bacter thermo
autofocus and down here you have the
coding region notice that we've matched
a certain part of the query sequence
which is nucleotide sequence and the
query sequence ends here and notice it's
on the opposite strand but notice what
we don't have is the coordinates of the
actual open reading frame and an
extension of this particular exercise is
to use that with our or finder tool
which is in the document to get the
complete open reading frame and in fact
if you do that you'll find that you get
a complete open reading frame that you
can use in the next example which is a
blast search against PDB where you can
find a structure model and a conserve
domain and we run over time more than I
intended to do so I think I'm going to
stop here and point you to the document
itself and you can take a look at the
additional examples that are in there
and hopefully you'll find them useful in
any teaching that you have to do so
there are five and probably six if you
count the two alignment based trees as
two different examples examples that you
can adapt pretty easily to teaching and
I think they'd be useful for developing
teaching exercises for undergraduate
courses on the last slide has lists
links to some URLs that are relevant to
the material we talked about today and
material in the handout the teaching by
example the five different ones are
available on our FAQ sheets directory so
let's take a few minutes for questions
away and if we have anything so one
question was for the ape mitochondria
search
why didn't Lemur show up in the results
good question the reason that lemurs
didn't show up in their results is
because I limited the database by using
an organism query and I limited it to
the superfamily hominoidea which
actually in our taxonomy database maps
to the common word ape that contains the
great apes which are the humans and the
chimps and the gorillas and in the
orangutan and Gibbons and thus I'm a so
the Lemur is a primate but it's not part
of that super family so the query
sequence does not show up in our results
if we had used primates than we would
have gotten the lemur sequence in our
results and one more general question
what's the difference between cobalt and
other multiple sequence alignments like
okay so the question is what's the
difference between cobalt and other
multiple sequence alignment tools like
close to LW the difference is largely
what the sort of trick that a lot of
multiple alignment tools use is they use
an initial guide tree to cluster the
sequences before they proceed with the
multiple alignment because it reduce
the amount of computation time that it's
required so what cobalt does it uses a
constraint and the constraint that it
uses is that matches to the conserved
domains that are in the proteins so it
uses that's what the the C and well it
stands for constraint based alignment
tool but the constraint that we use is a
conserved domains in the proteins
themselves to sort of begin to make a
guide tree to generate that alignment
and it's probably more technical
explanation than that in the COBOL paper
but that's the best one I can give you
right now
they all have you know their merits and
drawbacks multiple alignment tools okay
if there are no other questions so let's
conclude today's webinar if you have any
questions about this you can write to me
about those examples Peter Cooper and
nih.gov
if you have any questions about webinars
in general you can wait to work right to
our webinars address webinar is at NCBI
NLM NIH govt okay thanks everybody for
coming